they are desperately trying to hold
every inch of territory as Russian
forces continue their advance
and you can see how intense this fight
has become
soldiers firing their weapons
but what cover they have left is in many
places just the wreckage of what were
people's homes
troops remaining inside the city and
that one circled on three sides with
their main supply routes coming under
constant attack
crucial
the founder of Wagner yevgeni pragosian
whose mercenaries have done much of the
fighting is urging Ukraine to withdraw
his group releasing this chilling video
of him standing amongst coffins carrying
Ukrainian soldiers they claimed to have
collected from the battlefields
sides have sustained massive casualties
in what has for the most part been a
seven month Duel of Relentless artillery
the fragmented landscape Bears the scars
of some of the fiercest fighting of this
war
for now Ukrainian forces are hanging on
with commanders on the ground saying
they've managed to Launch
counter-attacks and have pushed Russian
forces back from one of the supply
routes
in this video the soldier dismisses
speculation they are already withdrawing
and says Ukraine is holding firm
[Music]
it may though only be a matter of time
before they are forced to retreat to
minimize losses
if they don't they face the Specter of
thousands of troops becoming trapped
without any chance of reinforcements or
resupply of ammunition
if Russia does succeed it will have
captured a city that's been almost
entirely destroyed
these drone pictures show the
apocalyptic scale of the devastation
and whilst the small city of back moots
may not have enormous strategic value
it's unlikely to change the course of
the war it will be a symbolic victory
for the Kremlin after months of military
setbacks Alex Rossi Sky News in Ukraine